Now one thing that looks a little
funny about this data is that every
value is a string.
But days to cancel looks like
logically it could be an integer.
Cancel date is clearly a date and
is cancelled looks like a boolean,
but they are representative strings.
That's because the CSV library doesn't
try to detect what type each column has.
It's up to me to convert
these data types if I want.
I could wait and convert them
later when I really need to.
For example, every time I need to
check weather is cancelled is true,
I could use the code, if is cancelled
is equal to the string true,
rather than the simpler if is canceled
that I could use if I had a boolean.
However, I prefer to update
all my data types upfront
because otherwise I tend to forget that
they're not the type I expect, and
then I waste time debugging later.
I've written some code for you which
you can find in your starter notebook
which updates a bunch of the types.
Here you can see the main
loop that's updating the types
of the enrollments data.
I didn't update the type of account key,
because even though the account key
looked like an integer, I'm never
going to do arithmetic with it.
I'm not going to add up
two account keys, for
example, so,
the types might as well remain a string.
I did convert the cancel date to
a python date time object, and
I wrote this function to do that for me.
First I check whether the date
is actually the empty string,
in which case I return None.
For example,
the cancel date could be an empty string
if the student hadn't cancelled yet.
Otherwise, I use the strptime function
to parse the string as a date time.
Don't worry if you've never
seen the strptime function.
I'm going to take care of the date
time handling in this lesson.
Similarly, for
the days to cancel function,
I've written a function
called parse maybe int.
This function takes something that
might be an integer but might not be.
For days to cancel,
it might not be an integer if
the student hasn't cancelled yet.
If the argument is the empty string,
this function will return None and
otherwise it will cast
the argument to an integer.
Then, for the is_canceled column,
I check if the value is
equal to the string true.
So this comparison will
return the boolean true
if the field is equal to the string
true and false otherwise.
The rest of the conversions are similar.
The only other thing that's a bit
strange is in the daily engagement table
where you can see that a few times
I've cast the number to a float first
and then an int.
To see why, I'm going to scroll up and
see what the lesson's
completed value looked like.
The first value for
lessons completed was zero point zero.
Because of the decimal point,
directly converting the string
to an integer would fail.
But, logically, I know lessons completed
should be an integer since if you only
complete half a lesson, you'll be marked
as completing zero lessons, not 0.5.
So, once I've converted the value
to a floating point number,
I then convert it to an integer.
I've done the same thing for number of
courses visited and projects completed.
This code is included in
the starter notebook.
Once you have everything set up locally,
you should make sure you
run each of these cells.
That way you'll have the correct types
throughout the rest of the lesson.
In general, make sure you run all
the provided starter code, or
some later code may not work correctly.